didn't say I gotta ask where you had all
intimidated to not only star in this
film but also directed heck yeah that's
why I took seven years I said I want to
do the play not like I'd want to do the
place so I can do the film yeah I want
to do the play because I want you to
play because I'm a theater actor it was
still a three-and-a-half-year working
out in my head process before I I said
yesterday wrecking it I wanted to say
yes but I needed to find out and it took
me a while if I now in this storm from
the 1950s or the story of this film
offenses in 1950s why is this story
relevant today at the center of the
narrative is a man who is an anti hero
hero meaning he is the god in his world
but the ante part is a part that's
flawed the part that even though yeah I
know I'm the father I know I'm the
leader but you know what I got bad stuff
that's going on with me too I don't
always know the answers I'm gonna leave
some bruises and scars I'm going to hit
I'm gonna cut but I'm gonna love you
anyway well because it's about the human
condition the human heart really never
changes you know there's love there's
fear there's desire there's jealousy
that's lust there's all these human
factors that are timeless and August
Wilson writes from a human palette
that's why his work is timeless and and
the value to press his value of family
so it can sustain you through any time
and and you know we were in sometimes
but we had some ties but not too high
for Stefan what are the three best
qualities of dans le directeur patient
very patient was the term mission
oriented yeah yeah yeah focus yeah he
knows exactly what he's what he set out
to do and he's not leaving until he gets
it yeah yeah and and and that he's
faithful to the writer oh no he's really
faithful to he's guided by all this
Wilson was there anything like advice he
gave you or a poignant moment on set
that kind of stands out that you can't
seem to like let go of I think for me in
the last scene that I had that Lions had
with cory i was having just struggling
with that moment and he just gave me a
very simple note that said take care of
your brother and once he gave me that
note the the scene just soared after
that
I think he leaves pearls of wisdom that
will stay with you long after the movie
and the project is over I always say you
know acting is about being private in
public it's about it's like standing in
front of an audience naked and turning
around really really slow that takes
courage it takes courage to direct that
it takes courage to be that that's what
he has he has all those qualities it's
not easy for me to admit that I've been
standing in the same place for 18 years
I've is standing with you I gave 18
years of my life to stand in the same
spot as you
[Music]
you